The following is a production of Frankie Fratis and the Internet Legend of Holography.
Hello everyone, this is Frankie Freitas, and welcome to another week of HoloTalk for the week of October 4th, 1999.
It's getting pretty close to the time where I have to upload this to the web.
In fact, it's 8 o'clock on Sunday night.
I'd like to have this up at least 9 or 10 o'clock.
So we're going to be doing this live tonight.
Our guest this week is Ray Ramirez, and he's going to be with us in just a minute.
In fact, I'm going to be dialing his number live here from the studio and getting him on.
Uh before we do, I just want to give you a few reminders.
The first reminder is this Wednesday, October 4th, 1999, and I put that date in there just in case someone's listening to this two years and you know, two years in the future in the archives, and they're thinking that it's uh this week uh in two thousand two.
No, this is nineteen ninety-nine, October fourth, this Wednesday.
Open house, the first one of the season here at the studio.
The topic's going to be laser transmission holograms.
Uh we're going to have a little talk about laser transmission holograms and then go into the lab and see some of the laser transmission holograms.
And these are really interesting holograms because normally people do not have an opportunity to see these outside of a laboratory environment because they normally or usually all the time require lasers in order to illuminate them, and therefore usually when you go to a gallery or you're in a holography shop, you see holograms on the walls or holograms on pedestals uh being illuminated with white light sources.
But on occasion you'll see a laser transmission hologram sometimes in a uh more scientific exhibit.
But this will give you an opportunity to see quite a few of these, and it's uh going to be a pretty interesting night.
So that's this Wednesday evening, October fourth.
Sorry, October 6th.
I'm sorry, here I am, giving you the wrong information.
This Wednesday, October 6th, at 7 30 p.m.
here at the studio in Allentown.
Send me an email if you'd like more information, or you can call the studio's number at area code 610-770-0341.
That's 610-770-0341.
Uh lots of upcoming guests uh coming on.
I'm not going to say who they are because sometimes we have to switch schedules around and things of that nature.
So uh we'll just play it by ear, and if you get on the Holo Talk email list, you'll be able to find out which guest is coming on for which week.
Uh John Clayer, who has been a guest on the show and was one of the earl very early players with the uh laser pointer uh holography uh has made a nice diode hologram uh using fiber optics and I'm going to get more information from John.
This is very exciting, especially for uh school projects.
So another aspect to laser pointer diode holography that you that we can put on in the books, and he says it's a nice hologram and uh using fiber optics, so we're gonna get more information from John in the uh near future.
If you have not upgraded your real audio player, excuse me, to the new G2 player, and it's a free upgrade.
Um I would suggest that if you're going to do that, please do that this week.
I have a brand new type of presentation that we're going to be adding to HoloTalk, which is the synchronized multimedia integrated language or SMILE, which allows the combination of audio, video, um, graphics, pictures, animation, all through the G2 player.
You do not need any special hardware, you do not need any special software.
You just need to upgrade your regular real audio player to the new real player G2, and that's a free upgrade uh at the real site so you can go there and download that and uh take advantage of some of these new programs that I'm going to be putting together for HoloTalk that you would not be able to take advantage of if you just have the regular real player because it does not support smile language.
Okay, it's getting getting about that time.
I'm seeing seven fifty seven on on the uh clock here.
I told Ray I'd give him a call at five uh five o'clock his time out in California which is eight o'clock uh our time here.
So I'm going to put this on po uh pose geez.
Boy I wish I could edit this.
I'm gonna put this on pause and uh give Ray a call and get him on the line so we'll be right back.
Hello, is Ray there?
Um yeah three minutes.
Sorry to keep every hello Ray.
Hi.
How are you?
Pretty good.
I'd like to welcome Ray Ramirez to HoloTalk.
It's uh nice to finally be able to get you on the show after all the great work that you've done uh with lasers and holograms with your Science Fair projects before we get started.
I was wondering if you could tell the listeners a little bit about yourself, uh what your age is, what grade you are, what s school you're in.
Okay, um I'm thirteen years old.
Um I'm in the eighth grade and I go to Terrafilles Middle School in Grand Terrace, California.
And I understand you started out last year working um with lasers and holography as a science fair project.
Yeah.
How did you get started with something like that?
Were you interested in science at the time?
Uh no, I I really didn't like science.
It was it was really boring and um I was looking for a science fair project and we had two weeks to do this project and uh went you soon 'cause I'm a big procrastinator and I wanted to dig over with so um that day I I found uh how a di how a hologram is made in a book and it was a little diagram and I thought it'd be pretty easy, but um i it hasn't been that easy.
But I decided to do it and I asked my teacher and he said that sounds like a pretty good project.
And it kinda opened up doors to electronics and all the stuff, but you really didn't like.
So before you got started you didn't really like science and then after you worked with it for a while you found out that it was pretty cool.
Yeah.
You were one of the first people to order my shoebox holography system back when it was just a couple Xerox sheets of eight and a half by eleven paper before it was into the booklet form.
Did you find that that helped you out a little bit?
Uh, yeah, it did.
Just um knowing that it's not that hard and you don't need a big expensive heating to make all your own, it's um it helped me out a lot.
Now you're the California State Science Fair winner, right?
Yeah.
What does that feel like?
I mean, science fairs are so competitive.
I mean it's you play baseball, which you know how competitive baseball is.
Uhhuh.
I mean, winning the California State Science Fair is like the World Series, right?
I yeah, I remember sitting at home and um I went to the California State Center uh website and I was I was just reading how all these people have done pretty good projects and and uh when the listing came out of everyone's project I sat there and circled the ones that might be a problem in it.
And um and I remember I was I was looking at the website a few months before the State Science Fair and hoping I might have a chance.
Mm-hmm.
So you had a plan of action.
Yeah.
And you went in there you actually took a number of science fairs getting there, right?
Uh yeah, there were three before the State Science Fair, so four total.
Wow, that must be an incredible feeling.
I never won a science fair.
I should have tried holography back when I was in school.
Of course I would have paid like ten thousand dollars for a heaney.
Back then.
Do you think that the uh the reason that you found this so easy was the fact that um the cost was so low as well?
Well, no, really when I first started I didn't know anything about the diodes and I really I didn't know you when I first started out and um and I was going to the PCC and viewing my holograms there, I made a few holograms there and I wanted to do it on my own at my house.
Yeah.
And then when you found out what was involved, what problems did you find with it that had to be overcome?
Having someone like Fred there just he knew what he was doing, but when I was doing it by myself it's um it's pretty hard to get a room totally dark and and just buying things cheaper have its advantages but they're all there's a reason why they're cheaper sometimes, they're not as good.
Yeah.
There were other kids that were listening to this that were thinking about doing lasers and holography for a science fair project.
Do you have any tips or suggestions that you would give to them?
Um, one of the big things that that people tell me I've done and and I think I've done a little bit it'd be very motivated.
Um it doesn't really matter how you get your motivation.
It it'd be very nice to to be self-motivated to want to do it yourself.
But you have to look for some reason why you want to do this and if like for example, if you don't like playing the piano, you're not gonna be a very good pianist if you don't practice and you don't want to do it.
So you have to want to want it.
What's your motivation?
Uh I just I don't know, it's Is it the wealth that all of us holographers have?
It's kind of the final the final product, what it actually looks like when it's done.
Mm-hmm.
Not too much from anywhere else, like it was kind of I could do it if I wanted to it wasn't there was no pressure.
What um what are some of your future plans for holography?
Do you plan on continuing with it?
Um, yeah, I I wanna I'm building a bigger lab at my grandparents' house right now and um kind of collecting stuff when I see it and hopefully I'm I wanna build a a post laser and uh maybe a YAG and I want to do some post laser holography and and some stereogram things like that.
Now you told you told me you may be getting one of the um green pointers in.
Yeah.
Yeah, a company has really close to giving me a green laser pointer and uh hopefully gonna do some experiments with that and and hopefully get some luck and make a few holograms.
Do you have plans for a website in the future?
Yeah, I I wanna start a website.
I'm I'm working on it a little bit and um I just wanna have some of the experiments that I've done and things like that on that.
Mm-hmm.
Oh that would be good for people to look up and get information on the uh experiments themselves.
Uhhuh.
Then you'll have to start answering all the email.
What do you think about that?
Uh it's fun.
I like to help people.
It's it's fun seeing people start off where I started off and and they're having some of the same problems that I had or still having it's kinda fun.
Now are you are you interested in art?
Are you going to pursue holographies and artistic means of expression?
Um no, I I know a few people who like the art part of it, but I really like the science part of it and like why it works and do that.
Um the art part of it is I don't understand all the art part of it and it's I like the science part but Yeah.
Yeah.
Well it it definitely takes a person who has the abilities in both uh the creative thought process and also the scientific thought process as well to ex to excel at holography.
Yeah it's I think it'd be great to have an artist start making holograms.
There's a lot they can do.
Would you like to exhibit your work someday?
Uh yeah, that'd be that'd be really fun.
Just to see people looking at my hologram.
Why don't you send me one of your holograms and I'll put it up.
Okay.
I'll put it up over at the uh Discovery Center, it's a new science museum over by Lehigh University.
Right now I'm I'm within the next few weeks I'm gonna try to do a uh shadow gram with uh with a laser pointer.
Mhm.
And uh that PC C and but so far it looks pretty good.
Gonna shoot it.
I'm not sure if it's gonna be on lava or agra.
But 'cause that turns out I'll thank you one of those.
Now what are the different materials that you've worked with?
Well I started off when I first started off I had a box of V plate with the fourth Apple pack.
Mhm.
And I blew all of those I got almost a hologram in one of them, but uh the other three I blew.
And I've used some ACRA and um Russian Russian film.
Mhm.
And you find all of them to be fairly easy to work with?
I hate the um the PFG O three M.
And it's really hard to work with.
But the run Yeah, at at low powers like that, right?
Yeah.
I was doing thirty second exposures and I actually got a little bit but not in the not in the O three M.
Mm.
And it's it's it's a weird processing how you process it.
But I like the PSG O one.
Now when you work with that, do you expose that film to any white light?
No.
Late sensification?
No, I think you do I haven't done it but I think you do it with the O three M, but uh Oh just the O three.
Yeah.
I I haven't done it with the O one.
Mhm.
Any comments you wanna make to anyone before we close the show out?
Um I'm just listening to people run up and down the steps.
I don't know what's going on upstairs.
I do this down in the studio and everybody's running up and down the steps.
I don't know what the heck's going on, so that's why there was a little bit of a blank space there for a minute.
Oh yeah I'm kinda I think I'm gonna go eat dinner right now.
You're gonna go eat dinner?
Yeah.
That's right, it's like five forty seven out there, right?
Well I'm gonna have this show up probably within the next hour so uh when you log on maybe you'll be able to get on and see it.
Okay.
Or listen to it rather, not see it.
Do you have real player G two?
Um or just real player?
Real player.
Okay.
'Cause I'm gonna be doing some pretty neat stuff with the G tube uh system.
Is that a free download?
Yeah, it's a free la it's actually a uh upgrade just from the five point oh.
Okay.
And it's free.
It combines a lot of different multimedia things and graphics and text and things into one unit.
Synchronized.
Did you do a um actual picture broadcast?
I'm going to start doing that with the G2, yeah.
Uh huh.
You have to start your own radio show so I can log on and listen to you.
I'm the only person in holography that can't log on and enjoy a show every week.
I'd lo I'd like to be able to just sit back you know with a cup of tea and uh listen to somebody do a show.
Yeah that'd be that'd be pretty neat.
So why don't you send me one of your holograms.
Okay.
And I'll get it up and displayed, put information up about you as well 'cause I know you sent an information packet as well.
And I'll make sure that information gets up there with it and uh get some people to uh see your hologram, maybe you get some email from them.
Get some fan mail.
And congratulations on all your achievements.
Thanks.
And you're pretty certain you're going to stick with holography, huh?
Yeah.
So um someone to keep an eye on folks in the next few years.
Ray Ramirez from California.
What city?
Riverside.
Riverside California, it's just outside of Los Angeles?
Uh uh an hour to an hour and a half drive.
Oh okay.
North or is uh Los Angeles north or south of you?
Um Southwest or maybe.
Southwest.
Okay, so you're f you're up further north.
You're up on the way towards um San Francisco?
No, down by San Rodino.
Oh, okay.
I don't know too much about California.
Okay.
Yeah, closer to San Diego.
Oh, okay.
All right, Ray.
Well thanks for being on the show.
All right, thanks.
And I want to wish you a lot of luck and a lot of success.
And I'm looking forward to uh following your future pursuits and successes in the field of philography.
I'll see you later.
Okay.
Bye.